if you blast it off with space wars here
are five other shows
totally worth checking out on this
week's binge guide
from the creator and star of the office
greg daniels and steve carell space
force is coming in rotten and audience
reviews are
mixed but if you love the work these
guys do here are five other shows
that'll have you laughing
all the way to the moon and back
starting with the certified fresh pick
silicon valley
with five out of six seasons coming in
certified fresh this comedy series about
the northern california tech industry
was co-created by mike judge
and helped make actors like thomas
middleditch and kamel nanjiani household
names
with the hilarious cast given the
freedom to improvise at times
fans definitely loved the laughs and
critics call it a relevant
often hilarious take on contemporary
technology and the geeks who create it
it will take you just under 25 hours to
binge the whole series and maybe you can
channel the character guilfoyle in it
who drinks a beer in
every episode next is our brand new pick
uploads this sci-fi comedy series which
recently debuted on amazon prime
was created by greg daniels and is set
in a technologically advanced future
where humans can choose to be uploaded
into a virtual afterlife
starring robbie mel and relative
newcomer andy allo
critics say the certified fresh first
season has witty writing and a winsome
cast that may get an afterlife worth
living
the first season will take you just five
and a half hours to get through and may
give you an idea of what you want or
don't want to happen when it's your time
to go our audience pick this week goes
to seth macfarlane sci-fi dramedy the
orville
with an average audience score of 94
over two seasons this show is set
400 years in the future and follows an
exploratory ship facing both
intergalactic
and everyday life problems with a great
cast led by mcfarland and adrianne
pilicki
critics call the orville fun focused and
surprisingly thoughtful
with a third season due out sometime
this year you're looking at 19
hours of bench time for the first two
seasons but in space time that's like a
fraction of a light year right
and for our throwback pick this week we
are going all the way back
to beep this comedy about a female vice
president juggling her public and
private life
ran from 2012 to 2019 with all
seven seasons coming in certified fresh
julia louis-dreyfus may have won
six lead actress emmys for the show but
critics love the sharp funny rapid-fire
dialogue from the
ensemble cast calling it a mix of smart
comedy and bright performances
it'll cost you just over 30 hours of
your time to binge this show but the
amount of interesting swear word
combinations you'll learn will be
[ __ ] priceless and finally our
editor's pick this week goes to
superstore
this nbc workplace comedy with five
fresh seasons gives a look at the lives
of employees at a big box store while
taking a comedic approach to
heavy timely issues with a charming cast
led by the emmy-winning america ferreira
who will be leaving the show next season
critics call a superstore one of the
most lovable ensembles on television
with a total bench time of just over 37
hours
superstar will give you a newfound
respect or maybe disrespect for big box
stores and their workers
alright friends hopefully this will help
guide you through your next few bench
sessions be sure to let us know in the
comments what you are currently
streaming and if you don't want to miss
out on any future episodes of this show
be sure to hit that subscribe button
and notification bell as always thank
you so much for watching the rotten
tomatoes binge guide and we hope to see
your face in the next video
[Music]
bye
you